we're with the Hollywood superhero and
how are you guys doing tonight it's
amazing it's by the way I love your guys
like radio show and it's awesome it's
fantastic that you guys spend so much
time and effort supporting independent
film and you know it really means a lot
you guys around
thank you so much no problem so you
wanna hear a little bit about our it is
about it's a drama it's about an old
lady comes to Los Angeles to find her
loss nephew he's gone off the grid he's
got a history of drugs in the past this
issue so he's worried about him she she
drops her last dollar to buy her ticket
to get here and has nothing but trouble
like the town itself turns against her
and she is literally gets no help from
anyone at the end of the story she finds
herself on Hollywood Boulevard and she
sees that there's somebody dress that
was the character with a superhero that
she knew our nephew loved as a child so
she wants one happy moment this one
memory
so she walks up to take a photo and
standing
fine here
test
is wonderful so do you
young man that you're sure to wait
Jonathan called her
triangle of his life it's kind of her it
was great
kind of dark man
late
we definitely have to throw a shout out
to Diane chambers are lovely on who's
ultimately the star of the film but she
gives everybody her love and she'll be
at the screening next week but you've
been like the garbage if you want to
check out anything about the elements
www Hollywood superhero
find us on facebook a few weeks the
movie will be available for every busy
online
Oh